quoique j'ai réfléchi pour tout le monde
j'ai réfléchi pour les femmes pour les
hommes pour les trans pour les uns pour
les six comme on dit maintenant j'ai
réfléchi vraiment parce qu'en fait il me
semble que le neutre n'est pas une
émancipation seulement pour les
minorités mais aussi pour tout le monde
c'est à dire même pour les hommes qui se
peuvent se sentir enfermés dans des
stéréotypes dans des manières d'être et
et dans des manières d'être killers et
qui les empêche par exemple d'avoir
accès à d'autres
d'autres champs de l'expérience humaine
à la vulnérabilité
d'autres la fragilité ou même en fait ce
qui vous empêche aujourd'hui de porter
des talons sur ce plateau oui mais voyez
vous je comprends bien que la binarité
entre hommes et femmes entre homos et
hétéros puisse être considérée comme une
bille mérite des binaires et et
aliénante aujourd'hui on veut être une
femme tout en gardant son pénis par
exemple on a fait à des bases sur ce
sujet une de mes amies t étais étaient
dans ce cas mais moi par exemple je veux
être une lesbienne et quand je me
présente à la porte d'un club de
lesbiennes on me laisse pas entrer
qu'est ce que je fais je dis que je suis
neutre
alors que vous vouliez être une
lesbienne c'est vraiment très bien pour
vous et j'ai dérobé jsk voilà c'est à
dire que moi ce qui m'intéresse plus tôt
c'est la manière dont les autres en fait
vont vous empêchez problème les légions
de la question des clubs minoritaires
qui sont réservées j'attends de voir ce
jour où vous ne serez pas accepter dans
un club si vous en a fait l'expérience
oui mais généralement c'est que là bas
il existe aussi parce que dans les clubs
grand public ces personnes sont
discriminés
[Musique]